what uh what do you do with your money
yeah yeah i know you got a ranch
uh
i think you live here
he's had that forever that i mean that
was like my house that so it's it's not
like it wasn't like a hot uh like a
luxury property or whatever like kanye
having a ranch in wyoming you actually
live there because you wanted to live
there sam sam i think has some some
similar aspirations
um but what do you do are you like i'm
an investor you just do something boring
with your money what do you do yeah uh
well i spent a lot of it on this
bookstore uh i i bought two buildings in
this in this small town of bastrop uh
originally there's gonna be a bookstore
in a coffee shop now it's a bookstore
and i rent out half of it to a a record
store but i wanted i needed like a space
to do all my stuff so up top is like my
office my wife also wanted me to take
all my books out of our house uh so uh
that was part of it it was like getting
all the out um but no i don't
really do anything i don't really do
anything with it i invest it
[Music]
i like investing in things
that are very different than internet
things so most of it's like in
income producing real estate
[Music]
how do you describe yourself you know i
don't do it very well uh
you you nailed i i would sort of if i
had to say what do i identify as i would
say i identify as a writer and then i i
sort of have these other things that i
do
in
that are somewhat related and somewhat
unrelated but like if i had to sort of
only pick one thing or like what what do
i feel like i was like
meant to do it's it's writing so i
identify first as that
sean do you remember this did i ever
show you this coin i used to carry
around i would have it with me a lot
particularly in the old san francisco
office i had a coin remember
no i've never never seen your coin what
do you do there's two face of me um no
it was it said um what did it say
momentous mentor
yeah which means like you're gonna die
you only live once right by the way
don't you love that sam carried it
around for years doesn't know what it
says on it
momentous
i knew that it meant like
you have to live today like you're gonna
die yes
right
and uh i was thinking about it
i bought one for 26
and i was thinking about i was like this
is the greatest business of all time i
just bought a
like a fake coin from ryan for 26 it
cost him it was just probably a post
like a stamp just to mail it to me so
only 50 cents
there's not gonna be any returns there's
no it's one size fits all and it made me
happy and i carried it around and i was
like this is the is that the greatest
business of all time selling coins it's
uh it's been it's been a nice business
better than the publishing business
right like what's interesting about
books is like like the the new book so
you spend two years of your life writing
something it's like 60 000 words uh you
have to you know the publisher is taking
managing all of it so you know they're
they're the middleman in all of it but
like that book is 26 and people if if
that book was 32 people would be upset
because there's like a
a sense of what a book should be right
like this is what people are willing to
pay
and regardless of how good the book is
or not it's exactly something of this
shape i pay either nine dollars 13 or
2016. yeah right and so
one of the things uh as as daley stoic
which i started as this email list
became
sort of uh big if the idea was like okay
are we gonna advertise uh are we gonna
monetize this via advertising uh or are
we gonna like is there stuff we can sell
that
you know makes it a business
to pay for itself and uh as we were
thinking about stuff you could do as
because i came from the apparel business
before i was a writer um i was like we
are not doing t-shirts under no
circumstances are we doing t-shirts
first off because t-shirts uh
uh are like are you know
it's kind of cheap you know but t-shirts
are the worst business you can do so
like bands become popular people build a
brand the first thing they always think
is t-shirts but what i remember is just
how complicated t-shirts are
first off because you have to get
someone to make them but if you sell one
t-shirt that's already at a minimum
three skus right small medium large if
you want to do extra large and and uh
extra small okay now five skews and then
you're like okay we're gonna do white
then we're gonna do black so now you
have ten skews right and it's in and
then then they don't fit there's quality
control issues all so i was like we're
not doing shirts and also like shirts
even though all of that people will only
pay a certain amount for sure because we
don't value it as a thing so um i would
think i was like i want to make
something that's better margins that's
less work all of that so i was just
really thinking about and then one day i
was at the airport i was at the austin
airport and i was thinking about this
idea of memento mori which is um like if
you look at a lot of old like
renaissance paintings the philosopher
always has a skull on its on his desk um
and so there was a philosophical genre
of like reminders of mortality and i was
like it would be really cool to have a
reminder of that what would that be
i was like oh i could get a tattoo and
then i was like i don't really want to
get a tattoo and uh so i was like what
could i have and the idea of the coin
popped into my head and it turned out to
be
really cool we actually used this mint
in um minnesota that invented the the
alcoholics anonymous chip like that you
get it like 10 years or 20 years so um
they've been in business since 1888.
wow that's i think i think we're their
biggest customer now um
uh and uh that also is a really cool
business that i've been fascinated with
but yeah that was that was close i'm
going to i'm going to ask you about the
minutes
in a second because i have another mint
that i think you're going to get a kick
out of but do uh can you reveal how many
of those coins you sell a year or do
you're not talking
i don't want to say exactly how many but
like ten tens of thousands uh it's uh a
lot of them and and people like i'm
giving a talk in
marble falls uh
next week and
like they bought one for each of the
attendees so it also became it's a
really cool way to like what i'm
interested in is not like tchotchkes or
like just random ass merchandise but
like what are phyllis
what are physical manifestations
of
the ideas that i talk about that could
actually provide
value in some way so like i have i have
this this one on my desk but then the
other one uh that i have this for my
others this is this one says tempest
fugit which means time flies this is
like a parenting one it's just a
reminder that like to be present as a
parent so i kind of start with stuff
that would be helpful to me and then if
if it works for other people it's good i
do think
entrepreneurs tend
to think about
digital products first and not physical
products that have good margins and this
so that's been really cool
well how much does a coin cost you a
dollar uh more than that uh because more
than that and then there's also
packaging and
all that all that kind of stuff but um
but yeah it's i'll just say it's a good
it's a good margin uh but um
but uh yeah it's a good mark not as good
as a digital product but good enough
that business i feel like um
you know i have this phrase you you know
you you are what you admire which is
like if you admire things enough you you
end up moving in that direction
and that's a type of business that i've
really like the thing the the little
thing you just said
gets like the highest amount of respect
for me like okay elon can send a rocket
to mars you know steve jobs can
you know where's turtleneck and do his
thing
but an entrepreneur who says well i
wanted to create i really was interested
in stoicism so i created this free thing
to give it away and i didn't know what
the business would be the traditional
model doesn't really work ads
um it would like you know how kind of
shitty would a stoicism newsletter be if
it was just plastered with ads
uh but i did it anyways betting on
myself that i'll figure it out and then
i figured it out first by having my
little framework of like
what's a thing that represents this
belief that has high margins that has
low headache
like i have a ddc business with over
like 3 000 skews so when you're saying
that my body's just like you know inside
just shriveling up and dying um and i'm
like oh wow how amazing would it be if i
had one skew that was just high margin
and like i could just make that skew
amazing um so hearing you pull that off
and uh you know the way kind of like sam
has it and people at the conference buy
it to me that's like you know top level
respect because
uh the creativity that that requires and
the thoughtfulness that that requires is
um is kind of amazing i think most
people would just kind of declare
creative bankruptcy and say i don't know
i don't know how to figure it out and
just never never that's why i think
shopify is going to be like the biggest
company in the world because they like
let people do that do you know what i
mean like you just come up with an idea
and then you know it plugs into a
third-party warehouse although i have a
fulfillment center here in austin where
i do some of the stuff out of the
bookstore but just like that you can
just come up with stuff and make it and
sell it to people is is to me is going
to unlock like so much
potential
um and part of the reason i'm able to
have the books to like a physical space
is that because most of what i sell
online can subsidize like uh in person
retail also
right sean have you heard of th this
story is going to come full circle but
not till the end have you heard of
stuart resnick stuart resnick no
all right i bet you've heard oh i think
i know this guy they own the pistachio
company right yes so when you go to the
store juice or whatever yeah so they own
this it's a privately owned company it's
probably one of the large
linda and stuart resnick it's probably
one of the largest uh privately owned
companies in america they do
multi-billions in revenue his he started
like a security business that he sold
and he got some money and then now he
owns palm wonder like the drink palm
drink he owns um pistachios and a bunch
of stuff anyway he one of his first
businesses after he sold his security
company made a little bit of money he
bought this thing called the
franklin and the franklin mint i knew i
knew ryan i knew you're gonna know what
this was and the franklin mint basically
started out by selling coins eventually
they expanded to a bunch of other
collectibles but they started selling
coins and up until somewhat recently
they are one of the largest i think
advertisers of digital and uh not
digital um print media and so like if
you would open up a magazine like a usa
like a tv and news guide like the
things they were always selling coins
and it was franklin mint and he uh sold
it for like two or three hundred million
dollars when he was done with it and you
know who bought it recently was tai
lopez oh wow didn't he buy radio shack
also
and a bunch of he's bought so much
stuff hold on
i'm kind of stupid what these mint okay
is the mint literally a coin factory so
they take metal that shape it into a
coin of your choosing and then they
they sell it uh or they they you know
they provide it to you who sells it is
that the idea is a coin factory is that
what a mint is
yeah although the franklin mint is like
commemorative quarters and dollars and
stuff right
but they don't but they do like they do
that no but yes they do but they got
actually sued because they use like a
princess diana coin
or they've done like a like a i don't
know like some like famous person that
like middle american moms like care
about you can buy like a coin with their
face oh
interesting i met this guy who has a
very interesting path that like
intertwines with the silk road and other
things
and uh he had said something like he's
like yeah what i'm doing now is i'm
buying these email lists of like
hundreds of millions of people like the
you know like the leaked
madison read or whatever what it was not
massive what's that
ashley madison yeah yeah email list for
like uh linkedin got hacked cool i'll
take all those emails and like you can't
you can't really even send to that big
of a list it's like too dirty and you'll
get like banned or whatever but he like
had some like expertise and how to send
mass emails and i was like what are you
gonna do with this like you start a new
thing and he's like oh no i'm just gonna
find people who like trump and i'm gonna
sell them coins
i'm gonna sell coins and hats to trump
fans and i was like i was like wow and
he's like yeah like if point two percent
of my list 0.02 of my list of whatever
ever converts uh like you know i'll just
make millions of dollars passively
sending these emails and i was like wow
this is the one of the craziest business
plans i've ever heard there's an
argument that fox news basically exists
for the sake of like reverse mortgages
gold coins and other forms of grift like
you if you watch fox news just the
commercials you get a sense of like
just how dumb the audience is to be
perfectly honest and then you realize
why the content it's almost as if like i
heard this great thing about spam they
were saying like like you know you get
an email from like a nigerian scammer
and you're like oh this is obviously
spam that's because it's not for you
right it's for someone who's dumb enough
to to not be
bothered by how all the red flags that
are there and so well even further it's
uh they want people who after they get
scammed won't really know how to like
have any recourse yes so they won't be
able to get back at you and so they
filter out all the people who have like
lawyers yeah and so when you watch fox
news and you get the sense oh this
exists to create the kind of customer
that would fall for these like obscenely
high margin almost criminal enterprises
i know this is an exaggeration but but
like right on this side of what's legal
or not businesses that tend to exploit
not very smart or savvy people that's
why the content is what it is is to set
up the commercial break where people
won't buy real things when you turn on
pretty much any other form of
entertainment you're not seeing those
advertisers because you're that's not
who it's appealing well this
it reminds me of an india uh and i want
to do a deep dive on this at some point
but there's like india has this culture
of gurus right so like
in first in terms of gods we have like
whatever 50 gods so the
then the gods all have like their gurus
and the kind of like the saints type of
people who give you know genuinely good
advice but then they also kind of like
do magic tricks and you're like to show
that they're like you know
you know the the man of god it's like he
can produce something in his hand but
it's like literally an illusion uh like
a magic trick
um but the way they work is they have
this like
virtue virtuous brand of being this
person who only wears their white robe
and they like don't have any material
possessions whatever but when you go to
visit them and people i mean there's
like miles long lines like going wait
like crawling up mountains literally
they crawl to show their devotion to get
to this person's like thing and then you
donate your gold chains you donate like
gold and so these guys inevitably
get raided by the government because
they pay no taxes and they like you know
are involved in crimes and they go they
find like tons of gold literally like
the physical the measurement tons of
gold in their house and they have like
then they'll like license these like
chip brands and like popcorn brands and
stuff like that and it's like the face
of this guru but he's selling like you
know potato chips dude vikram yoga
vikram yoga had ketchup i think
yeah it's crazy
yeah no it's uh it's it's uh
it's very strange uh once you get into
sort of the back end of how some of this
stuff works
do you know anyone ryan who's out
selling you in terms of coins if it's
selling more coins no i mean i do
sometimes wonder like when when um
when we order like we'll order like you
know a bunch of the coins from the from
the mint uh which is in minneapolis
they'll be like oh no we're really
backed up like sorry your order will be
like in a couple weeks or whatever and
i'm always like who is it who is ahead
of me um but but there there is i mean
so so i was thinking about it like i was
thinking like okay i wanted a reminder
of memento mori and then i thought coin
um and and it didn't occur to me because
i had a bunch of them already so i was
probably
but there is a genre of there's a thing
called the challenge coin that like the
military gives out or police officers
give out or firefighters give out
sometimes it's like a commemoration like
you visited this place but like if you
did like you know this tour of duty and
operation enduring freedom or whatever
like they'll they'll often give you
challenge points so i think a lot of
them are like
government clients or
um
uh
like
you know non-profits or organizations
like that but like i could get them done
like we're talking about margins they
would be much cheaper for me to make
them in in large bulks like from china
um but but we haven't done that we've
always used this this original place um
i wanted to do made in usa but then and
then as it happened during the pandemic
it was great because it was like we
never ran out of stock of any of our
products because everything we sell is
made in the u.s
that's awesome now brian i wanted to ask
you because you've done a bunch of
different things okay so you're uh
you're a college dropout correct
you um you worked for tucker max you
consulted with tucker max uh robert
greene who's the kind of 48 laws of
power or whatever um you've written a
bunch of books you've you own a
independent book shop you got your coin
business you sell courses all that
you've done a bunch of different things
okay so i wanted to play a little game
just to get to know you game
and um and it's called first worst best
best last week okay and basically it's
um okay so what was the first
job and it doesn't have to be like a job
it could be like a side hustle you had
so what's the first kind of dollar you
earned i worked at it i worked at a deli
at a grocery store called obexers in uh
in homewood california right on lake
tahoe
and what were you doing at the day like
making sandwiches and i worked in the
stock like just like a like a just a kid
i was 15 15 15 16 yeah 15
you know just like six dollars an hour
whatever minimum wage was uh in
california then just a you know kid who
worked at a little little small town
grocery and what was it like because you
make six dollars an hour i don't know
how many hours you're working but you
end up with like you know a couple
hundred bucks after you know a couple
weeks that's a lot of money to a kid do
you remember like what you did with the
money or how you felt about that that
amount of money at that time you know
what i don't remember what i i was super
into snowboarding so i probably bought a
snowboard or something um
but uh
yeah it occurred to me the i was just
thinking about this that i've basically
worked non-stop since i was 15 years old
like uh
then i worked at i worked at wendy's
after that if i remember correctly that
was a lifeguard so i've had like a
bazillion jobs but that was that was the
first one and then like i feel like at
age like 18 or 19 or something stupid
you're like the boss of american apparel
or something like just like something
ridiculous or like at 18 you like worked
for robert green writing 48 laws of
power well 48 laws of power came out
when i was uh like 11 years old but um
so not not exactly but uh i did i
started working for robert when i was 20
and then i was uh the director of
marketing and american apparel like in
my in my early 20s
so so you when you dropped out you
dropped out because what you just hated
school or you had something you wanted
no i liked school but i wanted to be a
writer and so i i had this i was going
to uc riverside so uh i was i was
working for tucker who was at that point
one of the first bloggers to to have a
book deal um so i was like i was working
for him doing like marketing and online
stuff and then he got me a job at a
talent agency um where i
did like yeesh i could not see you
fitting in yeah
i was like answering phones and stuff
but i worked on like new media uh like
so this is right like youtube had just
sold um so everyone's sort of interested
in internet talent so that's what i was
working on
and then um this summer i was at the end
of that summer that i was working there
i was supposed to go back
into college and within one week uh i
got an offer
to to stay on at the talent agency to i
was working for this movie producer
there to be his assistant uh and then uh
i'd met robert greene and robert green
needed a research assistant on a book he
was writing called the 50th law and so
uh
why did all these people like you why
did tucker hire you when you're 18 what
did you what did you do to get hired by
him because at that time he's writing
basically like funny
dating stories and sex stories right
like that was like his blog at the time
if i remember correctly i think i was
very young very ambitious very hard
working and i was just obsessed with the
internet like what what this sort of
internet culture would become
um
and i loved books like i just i've
always loved books and so i i think they
sensed that i wanted to be
a writer and
they sort of went under their wing as
like an apprentice
in
uh
you know how to do how to do what they
did
did you just cold email them so when i
met tucker because i was writing for the
college newspaper and i wrote an article
about him which is what i was doing i
would write articles about people in the
way that now you'd be like oh i want to
meet this person uh will you come on my
podcast right um yeah but but this is
before pocket so i would just interview
people and write articles about them so
that's how i met tucker i was a huge
robert green fan so i met robert through
uh
through tucker and then the talent
agency uh the guy
who i worked for was producing a movie
about tucker's book first book so
they're all sort of connected and then
it was through robert greene that i met
dov charney who was the director or who
was the founder of american apparel so
it all kind of was all swirling about
each other
and what was the first kind of like
personal hustle you did right you're
helping tucker achieve his goals you're
helping robert green achieve his goals
you're helping the talent agency find
talent when did ryan go into business
for ryan that's a good question um i
don't know what like the first thing i
would have
i mean i started my marketing company in
2011 when i was writing my first book
but i think the first big bet i made on
myself was
um
i mean i'd done other like little stuff
uh
before but the first bit i in 2011 i
basically quit at american apparel to go
write what was uh my first book trust me
i'm lying so that was like the first big
bet on myself
and that was a hit i mean that was that
was pretty it seemed like it took off it
got a ton i sold it for a good chunk of
money for for at least to me then um it
got a ton of attention
it ironically it will it sold well but
it will earn it will probably earn out
its advance
uh
by this summer which will be the 10th
anniversary of it like by
the the i'm
it's looking like the the royalty
statement i will get in july of 2022
which would be the 10-year anniversary
of the book it will finally go from pi
from negative to positive on the
advanced statement
what was your advantage i was two
250 uh it was i think it was 200 with
some incentives um although when i
announced it um i announced that it had
been sold for 500 000
because i know i knew people
nobody actually fact checks press
releases so uh trust me yeah so so the
whole point of the book was to prove
that like uh the problems i was talking
about in the in the media system in the
book were real so i i promptly uh
doubled the advance when i announced it
and and uh nobody nobody checked
that's funny did you um
so you got a big advance you didn't have
that big of a following at that time how
did you finagle
any advance let alone like a quarter
million dollars so it's your first time
so the bet on myself was that i i left
and i wrote the book first almost all
nonfiction is sold uh with a proposal
and then you go write the book but i
didn't i didn't necessarily need to do
that so i wrote the book so i had what
was
like i had a it's like i had a good
piece of property like i i wrote
something that was like unlike all the
other books
at that time
that i don't think really there's been
that many books like it or that i would
maybe um
chaos monkeys would be another like
similar book that i i'd sort of which i
thought was good um but but so i sold it
that way um so i wrote it so that i had
it um but it was mostly just all the
authors that i knew i sort of got in
because i i'd worked for tucker i'd
worked for robert i'd worked for tim
ferriss at that point so i had a pretty
good sort of rolodex of people
who got me in the door when i when i
sold that book
are you still doing the deals now those
type of deals now with all your latest
books or are you self-published i'm
still at the same publisher actually
i've done all my books with the same
publisher um
uh i've self-published uh a children's
book
and then i've self-published
two
high-end editions of
traditionally published books that i
have like i have a leather edition of uh
the daily stoic and the obstacle is the
way um but other than that everything's
been traditionally published i guess i
own the audio right so why is that
because like
from the outside you know i think a lot
of entrepreneurs feel this way it's like
oh publishing you know record labels and
book publishers it's all just middlemen
and they're they take advantage and the
authors see so little you know blah blah
and someone like you you have a a lot of
business sense b yeah now have a track
record c you have an independent
audience you can sell to
um
so there must be some reason that you
say no actually people don't get it that
you do want to publish it for these
reasons i look at it on a case-by-case
basis you're just you're really doing
the math um will uh
will the
what they're paying for it plus the
royalty um what
what are you
thinking you will earn you know in a
short amount
of time or you know in a certain amount
of time so i just do the math on each
project so every time i think about a
book just because i have a publisher if
obviously if no one was interested in
publishing it it would be a different
story um but i i you know i conceive of
what the book is and then i take it out
my publisher has a first look deal at my
books um i and i see what you know what
they what they think what they're
willing to pay and then you know i have
an agent and so we obviously try to get
that number up as high as possible um
and then once i have that number then i
think okay
what
would this look like if i did it myself
so what would it cost me to do it myself
what am i likely to sell myself um how
much work is that going to be how much
of a distraction is that going to be
um
and
90 of the time you know the math the
math tends to go towards traditional
publishing in my experience
um
the the kids book that i did the
publisher just wasn't uh
wasn't
it like wasn't in their wheelhouse they
didn't totally get the project um
but uh
so i did it myself it's been great and
really fun and artistically fulfilling
but also just an incredible amount of
work i mean like the coins i sell
directly from my store right
the manufacturer makes them they drop it
off at the warehouse they get shipped um
fulfilling books through amazon is like
in like and then also the thousand
independent retailers in the united
states plus every international edition
you know um
is extraordinarily
uh logistically difficult
um and i remember you you gave this talk
one time that was awesome where you
showed a chart of the sales of your book
versus the normal book so a normal book
you get a peak and then it pretty much
just kind of goes away but then for some
of the classics you get a peak and then
it goes down a little bit but then it
kind of quickly comes up to the point
the word even like it's pretty steady
throughout like a catcher in the rye or
something like that or even sometimes
it'll it'll it'll suck early on and just
slowly get better your books if i
remember correctly they they popped just
like everyone else they went down a
little bit just like everyone else but
then they like raised and were pretty
steady with daily sales and you're like
that's because i make that can last
a long time and this was actually
for when you're writing perennial seller
i think you're like proving this point
is is is that still the case and
considering all of your other businesses
is booked is making books still where
you make the majority of your income or
are you just using that because you love
it and it happens to make money and you
all but you make the bulk of your money
from other students yeah it's it's uh
most non-fiction authors make more money
from speaking than from books um
that's because speaking can be more
lucrative but it's also because most
authors don't sell very many books right
um so i'm in an unusual space where um
my books do sell consistently and i have
a lot of them uh so i make a good living
from that but probably make more money
from stuff other than books than books
uh all in dude that's crazy um
that that you're like the man and yet
still it's like the other well that
that's like that's another reason to
traditionally publish right so so like
uh
you you're a publisher does not take any
percentage of speaking does not take any
film or tv adaptations uh does not take
any ancillary products any merchandising
anything like that so really this the
book is
um it's not a loss leader because uh
people pay for books and and books have
value to people but like the the the
ideas in the book
everything else is downstream from
whether that that takes hold or not does
that make sense
um so if the book doesn't land all the
other stuff you know doesn't really
matter but if the book works all the
other stuff happens and then the success
of the book is slightly less
uh
less significant i think um
what my so so in publishing there's the
front list and the backlist front list
is anything uh within one year uh that
like the year of release that's
considered a frontlist title and then it
becomes uh a backlist title after a year
um so most titles stop selling when they
leave the backlist
when they leave the front list and
become on the backlist but almost all of
the income in publishing is from the
backlist
so so for me it's about like i've tried
to create that in my own
my own catalog of like titles that sell
every year um as opposed to
like a big book that comes out gets a
lot of attention then then three four
years later i have to write another new
book because the other one is like not
relevant anymore
it's like it's like michael buble or
mariah carey writing a christmas song
you know you you want that christmas hit
you want that a nude yeah yeah i mean so
so like uh my book the daily stoic when
when my agent was like we should do
a page you should do a page a day about
stoicism and i was like i don't know and
he was like it will be your best-selling
book and i was like there's no way that
doesn't make any sense he's like yes it
will every new year's like it will and
he's right the book sold
uh more copies this already this january
than last january
amazing what uh what do you do with your
money yeah yeah i know you got a ranch
uh
i think you live
he's had that forever that i mean that
was like my house that that so it's it's
not like it wasn't like a hot uh like a
luxury property or whatever like kanye
having a ranch in wyoming you actually
live there because you wanted to live
there sam sam i think has some some
similar aspirations
um but what do you do are you like i'm
an investor you just do something boring
with your money what do you do yeah uh
well i spent a lot of it on this
bookstore uh i i bought two buildings in
this in this small town of bastrop uh
originally was gonna be a bookstore and
a coffee shop now it's a bookstore and i
rent out half of it to a a record store
but i wanted i needed like a space to do
all my stuff so up top is like my office
my wife also wanted me to take all my
books out of our house uh so uh that was
part of it was like getting all the
out um but no i don't really do anything
i don't really do anything with it i
invest it um
i'm i like investing in things
that are very different than internet
things so most of it's like in
income producing real estate
in which state uh texas and florida
and you're just buying like what like
multi-family i have some multi-family i
have some mostly single uh single-family
uh and then some like vacation rentals
and you have a manager who
do you are you hands-on with that is it
a headache for you yeah i try i mean i
try to have it be as little a headache
as possible most of them are managed by
yeah property managers um
but uh but i like
it's not that i think that the stuff
that i do will go away but i like the
idea of like like my decision to write
trust me i'm lying and not having to
think about needing to sell it up front
um there was a similar one when after i
wrote trust me i'm lying i was like hey
for you know for my next book i want to
do this book about uh ancient philosophy
and they were like um
are you are you sure you know
so they gave me less than half i got 75
000 for the obstacle is the way um which
has sold you know many many times more
copies than trust me i'm lying um and
you know obviously set up all these
other things um but when they came back
with that offer i was like okay sure
whatever you know it wasn't i didn't
have to think about
whether i could live on 75 000 for
however long it took me to write the
book because
my life wasn't set up around
needing that's that's really like when
people hear a book advance it can sound
like a lot of money um like even you
know
two hundred thousand dollars right trust
me i'm lying so
but it's just like a salary right for
two years but even worse than that right
so i had to i let's say i left my job
and then 18 months later the book came
out um from from like when i left so 200
000 over 18 months that's that's pretty
good but like i said it hasn't earned
another dollar for 10 years so so over
11 and a half years uh 200 000 is not is
not great um but i really i wanted
that's the book i wanted to write and
obviously it opened up other business
opportunities but i like to be able to
do my creative work um and not have to
think about uh does it make sense in the
dollar instead and this is this is how
the entertainment business works as well
like um almost all the money is in the
catalog in owning the intellectual
property uh over the long term but you
can't do that if you are
dependent like you get paid as an author
every six months uh so and you're
getting paid for the previous six months
of earnings not like okay it ended
yesterday here's your thing you're
you're getting
essentially a paid from a year ago um
and so that's like you know that's a you
can be living hand to mouth that way
even if you're a very well-known person
who's in you know the media all the time
and so i i want to be in a position
where that's not the case
sean do you remember like uh seven maybe
2014 i think
basically when when you and i were just
getting to know each other uh there was
this article that went viral and it said
you can buy a ghost town in california
for like 1.2 million do you remember
that it was like you could buy like an
old mining ghost town yeah and people
did a group did it right and i think
yeah i saw your notifications
that ryan was involved in that i think
ryan and his brian so ryan correct me if
i'm wrong i've never met bro
my best buddy
oh really okay so listen to this shot
okay so neville is good friends with
brent so i've heard all about him so if
you go on youtube sean and you type in
like ghost town brent you'll see this
channel where this guy named brent he's
this really cool dude who's got like 1.5
million subscribers on youtube uh he
started living in this ghost town that
he bought a while ago but just when the
cove when pandemic hit he just moved
there and it it went to the moon and
it's the best youtube channel i've
watched well anyway ryan weren't you
like the
you and brent were like the mind the
brains behind it you were just kind of
the quiet i was one i was one of the
investors there's a there's a bunch of
investors i think we know uh you
probably know like half of them at this
point uh or more more than half uh but i
to be perfectly honest i thought it was
a terrible idea i was like you're you're
gonna lose all your money uh this is not
gonna work uh but i mean i've known
brent for so long i i just sort of was
like one of the small token investors
but i and i didn't see it becoming what
it was becoming i should have like
i was thinking about it in terms of real
estate because brett and i have invested
in in real estate in austin before and
so i was thinking about it in real
estate
and you know
being from california i was like that
area is like
like a pit you know uh
anyways uh i didn't think about it as a
content play and that's obviously what
what it
ultimately probably will become
i mean you could make more money off the
youtube channel than the actual
any money you could make off just
turning it into a hotel that's one of
the things i found with the bookstore
and that's kind of where where the it
clicked for me was realizing that so
opening the bookstore that like
that making money from selling books
might be the third or fourth
like
least important revenue stream or or use
of the property like the office being
number one uh
the
space to film and make stuff like
content being number two and then like
real estate being number three and then
uh you know like the actual uh brick and
mortar retail business being like four
or five
that's amazing so you basically are like
you bought a set the set actually just
kind of functions it's like what do you
mean it's like dude it's like
coffee
it's like 300 acres in the middle of the
mountains yeah have you seen it shawn no
no no no i'm talking about the bookshelf
but it's the same thing i mean the the
ghost town is an enormous set uh it's a
set piece to film and create content and
have a a life and a brand that people
care about you know and uh
so so hold on so it's been many years
now so what's actually what is that
today is there i don't watch the youtube
channel is there like a functioning town
do people come visit what
the pandemic obviously made a
hospitality business you know not very
viable so right now it's it's mostly
just in the sort of rebuilding phase
they're like rehabbing all these
different cabins and then he films you
know if some videos there and they do
like merchandise and stuff like that
it's really but like my son like my son
is five he watches one of those videos
every night before bed he's like
obsessed with it
it's beautiful it's like a beautiful
youtube channel it's and brent is very
endearing he's awesome
and it's crazy i mean it's crazy that
the quality of stuff you can make of one
person can make with like a drone a
gopro and like you know one decent like
sony camera like you can
i mean he it was at one point putting
out like a 45 minute video a week like
he was putting like a television quality
show out
uh
for millions of people you know for like
a couple thousand dollars a month it's
crazy what you can do
anyway it went from like zero to like
1.5 or one point i forget exactly over a
million subscribers in like 18 months
yeah i mean he got tons of media
attention it's done like hundreds of
millions of views um i'm very bullish on
youtube as a social network i'm like
late to youtube ironically considering
that's like what i left school to focus
on like i i saw at this talent agency i
signed their first youtube client and i
remember this agent
coming up to me and he's like what are
you gonna do you're gonna commission
their advertising revenue and i was like
i guess yeah and like that's like of
course that that's way better than
commissioning
checks from you know a television series
um because you just what you actually
own own the stuff but um i've seen it
even with it with daily stoic like like
as an author you get recognized like
every once in a while it's actually been
weird for me in the pandemic because
like i haven't done that much stuff and
so every time i if i go out or i do
something like i was i saw someone in
austin a couple weeks ago and then i was
i was just in new orleans and like
because of youtube uh and and like
instagram reels like the amount of like
fans i see in person it's like
exponentially different than what i was
getting from like who i was i see you on
tick tock like every day
you're in my tic toc feed every day uh
oh well i'm sorry to hear that
telling me to like you know uh thanks
marcus aurelius said yeah yeah tell me
something some ancient dude you know
said about you know remembering i'm
gonna die or like you know not not being
anxious about the future and i'm like
yeah actually
this guy's talking some sense uh i like
it and this and the the video quality's
actually really good um like i don't
know if you're i don't know what you're
doing for that but like it's like a
gopro that's a gopro 9 hero it costs 600
and you can shoot in 4k video with a it
doesn't even have an external mic it's
like it's crazy what you can do
but you could do a 4k video on your
iphone but when i upload on 4k my
never looks good i think the gopro
corrects but i don't know the gopro does
incredible the the lighting in the
building i have to say
not something i control is quite good um
well it looks like you're on like a farm
and you're leaning on
i mean the gopros are better for outside
stuff but yeah you just i mean just put
it there and it shoots like you know
super high quality stuff and then
somebody cuts it up do you edit or you
just hand that off to somebody you see i
like
and then i i try to shoot i try to think
about what i want them to make when i'm
shooting it and sometimes i'll give
notes i'll be like okay you know cut
this here or whatever but i'm mostly
yeah i mostly just shoot in like small
blocks um and then the idea is like okay
so if i'm shooting in a in you know
between 30 and one minute 30 second and
one minute chunks uh okay so that goes
uh a
content of that size can go on twitter
uh instagram as a reel it can be a
facebook video and it can be a
tick tock so you've got like
four
shot
four bytes at the apple there then that
content can be packaged together to make
uh videos on on youtube so i'll take
like eight of those and that can become
an eight minute youtube video um and so
so by shooting like these little things
i get like lots of different like
platforms that they can go out on
so basically um
well so ryan i i had i made a living
with a daily email sean sean just
released this new business that he's
working on which is amazing sean i gotta
reply your email it's called the milk
road it's pretty hilarious and it's like
a bit uh a crypto daily email that he's
working on with his partner ben but uh
you have the daily stoic which is
awesome but you have this new ish thing
that seems to be like working out really
well and honestly i think could be like
one of your bigger businesses i also
think it could be bigger because you
could sell it because it's not exactly
like the ryan show
but it's called the daily dad yeah so i
do two daily emails slash podcasts daily
dad and daily stoke
who's who's writing all the daily dabs i
write them all i write daily dad and
daley stoke what
how big is that business or how big is
the email uh daily dad is like 60 000
people i think um it's weirdly not as
big as i
want and not just want it to be but i
actually thought it would grow faster
than daley stoke did and it's actually
been a little bit slower um but uh how
big is the daily stove 400
oh my god really holy and do you
advertise to grow these or what are you
just through content then you capture
you you make videos i make content uh
social drives a lot of the sign ups um
and then the book i mean the book sold
you know well over a million copies um
but uh
but yeah so i write both of them and
then it's it's mostly organic but i'm
trying to i'm having to get more serious
about sort of i think some of the
low-hanging fruit's probably been picked
so i'm having to start to think more
seriously about it as a business not
just a content that i make man you
you you oh my god you're killing me why
weren't you advertising like three or
four years ago it was so much cheaper
you could acquire email for a dollar
fifty now it's like five six seven
dollars uh i i should have asked you
so you you're hanging out with people
all the time that are you know super
successful i know a bunch of people who
know you and
i think you're respected in the kind of
like the business world entrepreneurial
world
but i feel like the matthew mcconaughey
i feel like you you are uh pretty
grounded and you're i don't get the vibe
from you that i get from a lot of people
i hang out with which is just like more
more not enough uh i'm not there yet i
got to go bigger bigger and uh and
really it's just kind of like i haven't
succeeded enough yet i haven't earned
enough yet i want more money more
success
and i don't get that vibe from you are
you just hiding it or is that the case
um
i mean i definitely have there's
definitely a part of me that's in that i
mean i've written
12 books in 10 years if i was just like
oh i'm good you know like clearly
there's the drive
there uh or even some might say a
compulsion um i think uh
so so there's a part of it but i i have
so i've been with my wife since we since
i was 20. uh so we met like right as all
this stuff was happening and so and then
i had kids five years ago um so i've
always been
a little bit more
of like a normal person i don't mean
that in like a up way but i
haven't been like oh i'm a digital nomad
or like uh you know i'm i'm gonna go
live in puerto rico for two years like
you know like i've been more of just
like a regular like i don't say a nine
to five person but like i've just been
like more
rooted in like regular people life than
i think a lot of like creative
entrepreneurial people i know who i tend
to find are
a bit more like chaotic it sounds
judgmental but just it's a different
lifestyle and so i think that's i think
that's a part of it
no i know what you mean like for example
right now a whole bunch of my friends
are either you know like you said
they're crypto rich moving to puerto
rico they don't pay taxes they're going
to miami because i heard the actions
there right now i'm doing this doing
that and i'm just like but you know like
i just got i have two little babies and
i'm like what the idea of moving like i
mean the idea of like getting the kids
into the car to go to the park is like
overwhelming let alone
like uprooting my life in some way in
any way taking like massive risks now
just is not like appealing to me in the
same way like when i was 24 i remember
i moved i picked up i moved to silicon
valley i didn't know what i was gonna do
but i was like this is where the action
is i'm just gonna move to silicon valley
and then i ended up getting um this job
working with this like billionaire dude
in the office he had this dope office
and i remember i slept in the office
like 232 days out of the 365 days and i
was just loving it i wasn't like i was
being forced nobody's forced the the
office had an apartment right don't feel
bad it was like it was like it had like
two million dollars with the furniture
it was a lovely it was a billionaire a
better imagine peter thiel's office yeah
i wasn't sleeping in a garage like the
bathroom floor was heated in the morning
so your feet were your toesies weren't
cold so you know it wasn't super rough
but nonetheless i basically was
choosing to obsess and like go all in in
a way i was like excited about that and
able to do it in a way that i couldn't
as real life stuff layered on like
relationship and kids and things like i
remember when clubhouse blew up like a
couple months ago or six i was like what
like i was like i don't even want to go
to a real conference let alone be in
like an internet room conference like i
it was just totally inconceivable to me
that anyone would want to do it have the
time to do it it that's so that's sort
of not been i actually like writing you
know what i mean so the other part of it
is it's not just like the sort of uh
wanting to have more of a normal sort of
rooted life although i feel like i do
weird unusual i take risks in other ways
living on this farm and stuff but um
it was also like for me like i i
writing to me is a calling that's a
little bit different than
i don't know um making money in crypto
or something like it's it's a blessing
and a curse right it's a blessing in
that it's fulfilling it gives you
purpose
it's artistic it's like a thing you
master
there's also i think a ceiling on it you
know and like you can you can be good at
it there's obviously the jk rowlings of
the world but like you know um
but there's not a ceiling to being
famous i mean you know we're both
friends with tim ferriss and like his
fame allowed him i don't know what he's
worth but he's probably worth hundreds
of millions of dollars because of his
investments yeah i mean there there's
not a ceiling on being well known and
getting access to no but i mean you sort
of you end up in different niches right
if you if you're called to be a poet you
obviously would be more lucrative to
write business books but like
you are where you are you know there's a
certain amount of
uh like you don't choose what muses
visit you i know that sounds a little
mystical but like you i like sometimes
people have been like oh he's writing
about stoicism to get rich which i
always laugh at because like again i if
i if being rich was what was motivating
to me i would do literally anything but
this right like this is the worst
possible of the things to affect um but
i guess my thing is like i i really like
the routine and the ritual of sitting
down to write which is also i think
inherently a bit grounding in a way that
like
some of these other pursuits maybe
aren't
what does your uh normal workday look
like i mean are you are you doing like a
nine to five uh not nine to five like i
wake up early i i go for a run or a walk
with the kids whether we're at my farm
or my place in in town um
i don't check my phone in the morning
uh
i don't eat in the morning i usually
journal in the morning and then i go i
write usually for two or three hours
and then the rest of the day after that
is
business
other work stuff and i'm i'm done by
four almost every day so i'm probably
work
eight
thirty to four
seems like a good asset i like it
i try to i but i like it's important
there are also
i i don't know to me being really great
at what you do and
somehow managing to be like a somewhat
normal person
um
to me is actually like a rarer thing to
do than to
to just
be great at what you'd like i think if
anyone decided to be
like tom brady's tom brady but there's a
cost to being tom brady but like if you
choose to be that
singularly dedicated to what you do it's
easier to be better at what you do than
to say like
i'm gonna work nine to five and be
like
great at what i do if that makes sense
so you um used to work for tucker max
you then became buddies with them and um
you had a
a business together but i've never asked
either of you about this you've probably
it's based off of some of the stances i
know that you've seen you've written
some great stuff about like a letter to
your dad about voting for trump i know
that you're against like some a lot of
these statues and you've donated money
to that and uh tucker
i think has gone the other way where no
i wouldn't i don't want to call it the
opposite because of course he's probably
against a lot of the things or for a lot
of things you are but maybe different
and he actually recently came out this
article that uh sean and i talked about
it's called doomsday optimism and it's
about how
barry bluntly
but he's such a good writer that like
everything he writes it seems like
convincing but basically he talks about
how he thinks like the american
government is basically gonna collapse
in two to four years and how he's
preparing for doomsday and it was like
crazy fascinating but i what is your
opinion on that i've been eager to ask
you what you think about that and what
if you have an opinion on it
uh tucker was very good to me early in
my career and uh set me up for the
success that i've had so i feel very
grateful for that in a lot of ways
um
he and i live in very different
realities now
um i think
uh i don't know exactly what caused that
or or what
um
what
the driving force of that is i mean i
have some theories but
um
a lot of that stuff that i see and read
i think
it probably has nothing to do with
whatever he's talking about it's it
strikes me as um
as driven by
driven by something else
um which i've seen a lot of like i think
the pandemic brought it out in a lot of
people they're probably so we both know
but i've noticed a kind of a
radicalization
or
uh
[Music]
an untethering
from people
that otherwise i would have assumed were
in in alignment on i've just noticed uh
an untethering that i don't i don't know
where it's going but it certainly
worries me
is that a diplomatic answer
yeah and i don't really like that answer
because i understand what you're trying
to do i i i think you could you could
not agree with his opinion and still be
respectful towards a but i understand
that you're trying to like keep it you
know be cool but
like in one regards i could be like well
i i i unders
i actually could see ryan thinking
almost something similar because he
lives in the country and he likes
privacy and like he you know you're like
so so high iq that high iq people
typically are like quirky and have like
weird opinions but then on the other
side i know like some of the things that
you stand for and i could see you just
laughing at that being like what are you
ridiculous
uh but it's it's it's it's weird i i've
noticed this sort of trend in like sort
of tech entrepreneurial people where
i don't want to say fads but it's almost
like these idea viruses sort of enter
the community and some people end up
taking them to like very strange
extremes so like
polyamory was one a few years ago and
then crypto is one i i i have like i'm
not anti-crypto i i i think there's a
lot in crypto i'm invested in it too but
then then it then in the pandemic there
was like then there was this sort of
anti-vaxx uh anti-lockdown anti like
coveted denialism that was one and then
i'm i'm very alarmed
by
some of the people that i know in that
space that are now going in sort of um
like a it's worse than a trumpian
direction it's more of like a january
sixth like uh end of the gov like a like
a toxic uh like we gotta buy guns and i
have guns but there's this like almost
like uh
like doomsday
like disaster cultish direction that
it's going in and i don't it strikes me
as coming from somewhere other than like
what they're actually say it's coming
about does that make sense
and by that do you mean uh
the
belief is coming from some other like
kind of reasons or
the motives meaning like
trying to make money yeah like if we
perpetuate this we'll get more notoriety
we'll get more money we'll get more
attention like you know there's some
people like clickbait in general is that
right like i may not believe this like
if you watch a sports talk show on espn
they don't necessarily think that lebron
james is better than michael jordan but
they know if they say it it gets clipped
and it gets shared and so there's like
this yeah i do i perform
versus like do you think that the belief
has come from somewhere or the motive
might be driving them to extreme you
know radicalization i think it's both
those things so i think number one uh
all these people are are very smart
right and so if you've built your whole
career being smart and being a
contrarian it can put you in an
uncomfortable position where you're like
rejecting things that make sense because
that's instinctively where you go like
this is what happened with with with
dove at american apparel his whole cr
everything he did was insane i'm
gonna start a usa apparel company i'm
not gonna use professional models i'm
gonna pay a living wage none of that
makes any sense that was all those
individually or very bad ideas but he
somehow built a billion dollar company
out of it so then when people were like
you need to hire a professional operator
uh inside you know you need to hire a
real cfo and a real cmo and all this
stuff he was like no right so he just
got used to rejecting everyone's advice
and it led to this downward spiral so i
think that there's a little bit of that
i think there's um
i think there is this sort of as people
uh
become like
i think there's you know what audience
capture is where you sort of get used to
telling the audience what they want to
hear and so the algorithm is very
seductive it tends to reward like
obviously controversial things it
rewards uh you know uh
polarizing things and so i think what
happens as certain people's relevance
slips
they are more prone to
it's like you know you're always putting
stuff out and if what you've put out and
in the world hasn't been working
and then suddenly you like you chance
upon something as as uh compelling as
like anti-vaxx or uh this or that that
then if you it's like you're getting
it's like a blast from the past you're
like this is it right so i think
there i think there's some of that uh
that that's taking that's spiraling
people i also think just the pandemic
with people's head it's been a
long life
we're not meant to live like this i
think it's that um the other thing like
in like a joe rogan or some of the
intellectual dark web people i'm also
noticing i just like when you've been
very mistreated by like say the media or
just like elite culture um
it's very hard for you to agree with
those people even when they're right so
you end up going back to the
contrarianism you end up like
going against things that ordinarily you
wouldn't agree you would totally agree
with but from a tribal perspective
um
you know you you
it's imagine if trump had gotten
reelected like how many liberals would
have trouble with the vaccine because
you would have to then agree with a
trump thing um i think i think we're
seeing
that i think this is why in a lot of men
who have been uh sort of not media
darlings are going towards some of the
direction of things we're talking about
it's just a sort of like i'll die before
i agree with those people on anything
right
there's a there's this chart i saw that
was amazing it was in a cr it was in a
crypto annual report and i said yeah
what is what are some of the underlying
things that drive
this like crypto's like a religion it's
like a cult it's like this very very
strong it's not just the same as like i
like this business i i'm gonna invest in
this asset you know people don't feel
the same way about bitcoin as they do
you know a piece of property in dallas
and so
it was this chart and the chart
basically was on the on the on the
y-axis it was like
do you believe it was about institutions
it goes do you believe that institutions
are
like credible or not credible meaning
like are they honest or are dishonest i
think the way they put it and then on
the other side was are they competent or
incompetent as i rank these institutions
i was like the us government it's like
dishonest not not competent incompetent
and then it was um the cdc and it's and
it showed how they've been moving over
time and basically every institution
that you can think of whether it's
universities whether it's health
organizations the nih and who and cdc
whether it's the us government they are
all
sort of traveling towards dishonest and
incompetent as the general public
viewpoint of them and this has a bunch
of implications it's like well so people
so the things that reject institutional
beliefs so you see joe rogan just
explode in popular you know he's bigger
his show is bigger than quote unquote
mainstream media he is more mainstream
than mainstream media but his brand is
not an institution and he doesn't look
like them he doesn't read off a
teleprompter and so he's got this like
appearance of higher honesty higher
competency and so the same thing is true
with crypto which is non-government
money and blah blah blah and so all
these things are like on trend right now
and that doesn't necessarily make them
more honest and competent but it is the
perception that's good yeah and
when i was listing the different things
the other one i put in there is i think
like psychedelics is another one where
it just becomes like this idea virus and
i'm not saying that i have a
disagreement about it i just it's very
interesting how these things just sort
of infect these different subgroups and
become
almost a new it's their identity is
primarily in that the the
it's like
it's very tempting to fall into a thing
where you're smarter or better than
other people that sort of outsider
mentality and so i think
i'm just i'm very wary of how that's
affected people that i know and i'm
worried it's taking
some of the more fragile people into a
dark potentially dangerous direction
where they're just they're with
things that once you with they're
very difficult to unfuck
and speaking of
psychedelics and we'll wrap up a second
here um
i saw i follow uh so we've talked about
aubry marcus on the podcast because
aubry has a crazy story because his dad
liking invented like the fleshlight and
then he like kind of parlayed that into
building this awesome
uh supplement empire but i got this
instagram ad or maybe i just saw on his
page so sean i don't know if you saw
this aubrey marcus the guy we talked
about he has this documentary where
somewhat recently he spent i think
seven days in complete darkness like and
and i heard maybe it was in sarah gordo
am i getting the details no it's
definitely not at saragodo
okay well for some reason i thought it
was at yours okay i'm wrong then but did
am i right though and that it was like
five or three or seven like a multiple
days in complete pitch i don't know i
haven't i've not heard about that but i
am uh oh man i like aubry alive i've
known aubry a long time but he's he i
i'm a little worried about him
he he he's a wild man sean you didn't
see this so
basic idea why did he do okay so
so basically he had a uh a night vision
camera looking at him and he was in a
small room with a bed and basically
pitch dark and
after 24 hours or something like that he
kind of starts hallucinating and kind of
goes crazy and he's talking to himself
and the whole documentary is
is basically showing the night vision
camera of him talking to himself and
then like a voiceover and some
flashbacks of him talking like what he
was experiencing to that point and he
was trying to go through like almost a
psychedelic experience because i guess
there's something where i don't know the
science behind it where you're in the
dark for a long time you start going
nutty and have some realizations i don't
know if it's true or not
but it was insane it was crazy i
mean
the way that i see it is like
to me it's like i don't care if i'm an
outdoorsman if i see a huge epic
mountain i'm gonna be in awe and that's
how i was with aubry marcus in this
documentary i'm like i don't care about
drugs i don't care about this guy that's
not that much you just saw the ad i just
saw i i watched parts of it i started
watching parts of it because he released
like five minutes at a time on his
instagram and i started watching parts
of it he is it's the craziest
thing i've ever seen the guy's insane uh
you have to watch this it is why
did he come out okay
or you haven't gotten to the end
well this was filmed like a year ago and
he was on instagram so so we assume it
all worked out okay well
the reason i didn't buy it is it i'm
afraid i'm kind of afraid to watch it
but like he's wild man because i watch
his instagram and i see some of the
he does and i'm like this is i'm just
i'm very i'm very concerned that these
people are messing with their brain
chemistry in a way that it's hard to
come back from and you know
uh i i i am
not a fan of uh this sort of like uh
prescribed medicine for yourself to heal
unnamed traumas like i i think it's
going to end very badly maybe i'm a
little conservative uh
and i'm missing out on something but i i
don't think you should with your
brain the way some of these people are
with their brains and i think
it's gonna i think we're art we're
starting to see some of the
ramifications of it with some of the
stuff we're talking about here but i i
think this is hard to put back in the
bottle
yeah this this is wild this is are you
looking it up yeah i'm reading about it
right now what does it say
is it seven days it was like days so
like okay there's a part of this i can
get behind which is like you know people
whether they go try to climb mount
everest or wim hof getting in a cold
black cold bath every day
to like you know challenge themselves to
like uh like it's a you know there's a
form of meditation for example so he
says my thinking was this if the
prospect of sitting in the dark with
just your own thoughts frightens you
maybe that's exactly where you need to
be oh my god
rattlesnakes scare me too i don't need
to get bit by rattlesnake
and so on for me there's a part of this
that i actually like i get part of that
which is like
um i think the more comfortable you
could be with yourself and by yourself
and not need stimulation not need others
not need constant entertainment i do
think that that is like a direction
personally that i would like to go in
where i can i can be at peace and
happiness without something going on now
in this and this one i think is less
it to me it's less scary than like being
like yeah i'm gonna start micro dosing
lsd or like i'm gonna go on this
ayahuasca trip in the forest
because i heard joe rogan say that it
was transformational to me that's like
way higher risk and um maybe not
necessary compared to you know i guess
this darkness thing is a little bit less
permanent feeling for me but i mean
that's what they do
to like break them i i don't think it's
something you want to be messing with
but
again yeah maybe it is like deeply
traumatic i'm not sure hey you know what
the phrase is whatever doesn't kill you
makes you weaker
seriously man i don't i don't know
whatever doesn't kill you you up
really bad the way i always read these
is to me these are like um
these are content stunts right this is
no different than jackass and a bunch of
other things like maybe some people come
from a good place and i'm just kind of
skeptical about all this stuff like for
i'll give you ryan i'll make it personal
for you which is like when i saw the
daily stoke i was like oh that's smart
stoicism is this growing trend he
probably likes stoicism but like
you can like it without having to do all
the work of creating a daily email and
content around it like
that is the opportunistic side of this
like kind of cool niche thing that's
clearly growing and i've said i i don't
know you right so i'm just thinking from
a farm thinking oh that's smart
um and you know he probably recognized
this growth and said okay i could build
a cool brand around this thing that i
like and i see is growing and so when i
see
and you know so for example if i see you
making a tick tock every day about
stoicism i think to myself well
you know uh
i don't know how
much of that is like well this content
is gonna work so i'm gonna do it versus
i really just needed to get this off my
heart and share this with the world so
similarly when i see you know these
stunts i think to myself well they know
this is content that's gonna hit and
they can get a bunch of attention from
it and like did he really need to do
this and want to do this i'm not sure
right those motivations get mixed i know
for myself they get mixed because
um
you know if i i've had a bunch of tweets
go viral you know i added 200 000
twitter followers last year it's very
addictive and
in uh i don't know if you saw his uh the
the um the stand-up special that that
hussain is doing but did you see him
when he was in austin he has this part
in it
did you see when he was in austin i saw
him in san francisco i live in san
francisco so i saw him when he was here
and he's got this whole part where he's
basically like you know
he's like i challenged you know this
dictator who was doing this thing and
then boom that clip goes viral i made
fun of trump at this thing boom that
clip goes viral the likes the views the
followers the comments and he's just
like inject this into my veins i
need that next hit so i went after the
next big dictator and then the next big
fish and then all of a sudden like you
know there was a price to be paid for
and he talks about how he received
something in the mail uh that was like
you know something like anthrax looking
thing and it got on his kid and it
turned out to be all okay but like
his wife was like dude you have to
figure out how to keep maybe you
shouldn't be poking it's very important
and that's kind of what you're talking
about right right there you got to
figure out how to keep that on a leash
and i think about that a lot and i think
about it you know even with what i do i
remember
i was uh i was on some big morning show
and i remember thinking like
there's a
i know what i could do to make this like
national news like i know i could i'm
i've got a you know an audience of
several million people right now what
what and then just going like life is
too short and also i want to
continue to live in reality and so i
think what happens is certain people get
desperate or maybe their judgment is not
good or they don't have someone in their
life that's like uh you know that could
work but what about this this this and
this
as a consequence and uh you can
you can become unhinged very quickly um
especially if there is
any also
you know uh
comorbidities with like a mental illness
or you know like and so i it most of the
people who want to be in the public eye
you're already a little you know like
that uh and so you got to be really
really careful and i'm i'm worried about
where some people i know are going
yeah sam as a fitness influencer i've
been wanting to talk to you also about
your excessive exercise and what this
might be leading to
hey man you might spend three days in
darkness only doing squats uh just to
you know hit those views i'm in a good
place my friend i'm i'm doing everything
right at the moment we'll see how long
that could last ryan this has been
awesome man i appreciate you coming on
this is fun um thanks for thanks for
coming in the they didn't even say the
name of the book courage is calling
right
um it's awesome i i've not read that one
yet but i'm gonna buy it i've read
everything else perennial seller
obstacles away conspiracy i guess i've
read four conspiracy and um
um
uh trust me i'm lying and then the
middle two are just the stillness one i
haven't read that one stillness this is
the key and then ego is the enemy is the
one i think they're missing
the ego is very good and obstacles
always very good those are both both
great well and you're awesome i
appreciate you thanks coming
[Music]
you